[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'appelle natacha calestrémé je suis
journaliste réalisatrice de trente et un
documentaire qui ont été diffusées à la
télévision
j'ai également présenté une émission qui
s'intitule et sur les chemins de la
santé depuis sept ans j'écris des romans
psychologiques
mon métier c'est d'étudier d'analyser de
comprendre afin de partager
il ya trois ans j'ai perdu une amie très
proche des suites de harcèlement et de
manipulation perverse
elle en est morte et je n'ai rien
compris je n'ai pas compris que c'était
si grave
je n'ai pas trouvé les mots pour l'aider
à partir je ne pensais pas qu'on pouvait
mourir d'épuisement
à force de harcèlement elle me disait
l'horreur qu'elle vivait je lui disais
mais s'il est si terrible que ça qui te
le n est pas arrivé et une fois de plus
je n'ai pas compris pourquoi
comprendre son histoire et celle de
milliers de personnes qui vivaient cette
manipulation est devenu ma priorité
autour de moi tout le monde avait eu une
explication sur son absence de réaction
on me disait elle est masochiste
d'autres me disait alain ventes sont
mariés tellement formidable d'autres
encore me disait elle n'a pas de volonté
faible est le mot qui revenait le plus
souvent il suffisait de dire stop
c'était pas compliqué et pourtant mon
ami savait ce qu'elle ne voulait pas
elle savait me dire lorsqu'elle n'était
pas d'accord avec moi
alors pour quelle raison
était-elle si impuissante face à la
violence des mots de son mari après le
choc de sa mort
j'ai mené une étude sérieuse j'ai fait
ce que je fais toujours lorsque je
prépare un film ou un livre une étude
sérieuse qui a duré deux ans je me suis
rapproché de psychiatres de psychologues
j'ai rencontré des victimes je me suis
rendu compte que le processus de
l'emprise la manipulation est très bien
connu est parfaitement décrit tout ce
qu'elle m'avait dit mais revenue au
début il a été un prince charmant
elles adorent et le rock
quelle chance il adorait le rock l'adoré
et la cuisine japonaise
quelle chance il adorait la cuisine
japonaise
il crée un mimétisme pour faire croire
aux contes de fées
et puis au bout de six mois
le masque est tombé il a montré son vrai
visage
le harcèlement les dénigrements les
humiliations sont arrivés il soufflé le
chaud et froid en permanence ce qu'on
appelle les injonctions paradoxales les
jolies cette robe
c'est dommage que t'es pas de poitrine
en fait mon ami ne voyait pas vraiment
ce côté harceleur et penser plutôt que
c'était des maladresses elle me disait
ce qui me gêne le plus c'est de ce sont
ces silences justement il me disait un
soir je prépare le repas pour 2 il
arrive après avoir dîné et il m'insulte
en me disant que je jette l'argent par
les fenêtres le soir suivant elle ne
préparait pas leurs pas pour lui bien
entendu il rentrait sans avoir dîné et
l'insulté de ne plus compter pour elle
il a continué les dénigrements en
s'attaquant à son entourage
des parents sont nulles des frères et
des soeurs
ça vole bas puis alors tes amis n'en
parlons pas j'ai compris ainsi qu'ils
cherchaient à l'isoler et y est arrivé
son travail est devenue sa bouée de
sauvetage
alors il lui a dit qu'on l'exploité et
qu'elle ferait mieux de démissionner mon
ami a perdu sa joie de vivre
ces sourires
elle s'est mise à trembler elle me
disait qu'elle n'avait pas le mode
d'emploi
elle a consulté un psychiatre pour des
problèmes d'anxiété de sommeil pour des
problèmes de confiance en soi et l
estime de soi découvrir les processus de
reprise m'a permis d'ouvrir les yeux sur
ce lavage de cerveau qui s'opère dans
l'intimité mais certaines questions
restées sans réponse pourquoi mon ami
n'est t'elle pas arrivé à partir une
fois qu'elle a ouvert les yeux sur la
perversité de son mari pourquoi des
milliers de femmes et d'hommes qui
connaissent la manipulation la
perversion et qui avait réussi à partir
reviennent auprès de leurs bourreaux et
enfin pourquoi ceux qui connaissent la
manipulation rencontre encore et
toujours
d'autres manipulateur je suis
journaliste et cartésienne mais si
m'ouvrir à d'autres hypothèses
permettait de répondre à ces questions
j'étais partante j'ai rencontré des
énergéticiens et tout à fait sens je ne
suis rendu compte que le corps médical
et les médecines parallèles disait la
même chose avec des mots différents
j'ai découvert que lorsqu'on a une grave
blessure
notre corps nous protège il produit des
endorphines pour nous éviter de souffrir
et que notre coeur n'explose de douleur
face à la violence psychique le corps
fait la même chose il nous protège
devant l'inconcevable d'un proche qui
est censé nous aimer
et qui nous fait vivre l'horreur une
partie de nous s'extrait pour éviter de
devenir fou de douleur
ce que les psychiatres appellent la
dissociation en est comme étranger à la
situation
on observe ce qui se passe comme si on
était à l'extérieur de son corps une
forme de passivité inexplicable en
termes clinique s'appelle il s'agit d'
une sidération une fuite mentale disent
les psychiatres les énergéticiens parle
de perte d'âme
la première fois que j'ai entendu ce
terme
j'ai pas compris ce que ça voulait dire
une perte d'âme
puis je me suis souvenu de ce que
disaient les vétérans de guerre mais
aussi ceux qui avaient vécu un drame un
viol un accident ici j'ai perdu une
partie de mon âme
l'âme
qu'est ce que c'est finalement ni plus
ni moins qu'un mot qui symbolise tout ce
qu'ils véhiculent la confiance en soi
l'estimé de soi la façon de penser et
notre énergie est que ak fait le
manipulateur il nous a pris notre
confiance en soi notre estime de soi
l'autre façon pensée et notre énergie
l'énergie
j'avais besoin de me rassurer qu'est ce
que c'est je suis allé rencontrer des
scientifiques des physiciens
ils m'ont expliqué que notre corps est
constitué de milliards de milliards de
molécules et que chaque molécule est
rempli et est constitué de plusieurs
atomes un atome c 0,0001 % de matière
le noyau et 99,9 9 9 9 % de vide
sauf que d'après la physique quantique
ce vide est en réalité rempli d'énergie
et d'information cela signifie que notre
corps est constitué de 100 fois plus
d'énergie et d'information que de
matière on peut donc considérer qu'une
partie de notre énergie puissent être
affectées par nos traumatismes
cela crée en nous une blessure par
lequel s'échappe notre énergie vitale
les énergéticiens précise que cette
énergie vitale
les manipulateurs s'en nourrissent ils
affaiblissent l'autre pour se sentir
mieux une forme de vampirisation
inconsciente et ça expliquait tout
pourquoi mon ami n'est t'elle pas arrivé
à fuir son mari parce que l'autre avait
une partie d'elle une partie de son
énergie
pourquoi des milliers et de femmes alors
qu'ils ont fait le plus dur ils sont
partis reviennent parce que l'autre à
une partie de soi une partie de notre
énergie
si on me coupe le bras et qu'on le cache
dans les coulisses et qu'on me dit
natacha tu peux partir je vais peut-être
m'en aller mais je vais revenir pour
chercher ce qui m'appartient
ce n'est pas son bourreau que mon ami
n'arrivait pas à fuir sa propre part de
lumière cette fuite mentale dont parlent
les psys cette perte d'âme donc par les
énergéticiens
disparaître s'opérer lors d'une
manipulation la vue mais également lors
d'un choc lors d'un accident grave lors
d'un drame cela crée une faille en
nouveau par lequel le manipulateur
peuvent rentrer pour mieux nous
contrôler j'ai découvert à travers mes
recherches que cette énergie qui nous
manque cette partie qui nous manque
on peut la récupérer on peut la
récupérer dans un protocole énergétique
très simple je vais pas le partager ici
parce qu'il faut être prêt quand c'est
bon moment pour vous monsieur c'est pas
forcément pour le bon moment pour vous
madame
c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit un livre
qui s'intitule les blessures du silence
quand on est prêt tout était gris à
l'intérieur je voulais donc partagé ceci
si vous avez le sentiment de perdre de
l'énergie sans cesse de ne pas diriger
votre vie comme vous l'entendez de ne
pas maîtriser votre futur ce qui le
thème de ce tedx alors cela signifie que
peut-être vous avez vécu soit quelque
chose de très dur un traumatisme soit
une manipulation durant votre enfance
il est important de savoir que depuis il
ya une partie de vous qui s'épuise à
rechercher cette énergie mais que vous
pouvez la récupérer après on se sent
apaisé
je reçois quantité de témoignages de
personnes qui me contactent via facebook
et qui me disent qu'elles n'ont plus ce
vide en elle que depuis le protocole
elles ont cessé d'avoir peur
certainement dit j'ai cessé d'avoir
toujours faim j'ai gagné en sérénité
on est bien que lorsqu'on est entier
j'ai voulu comprendre j'ai voulu trouver
des solutions puisque je n'ai pas pu
l'aider
les partage avec vous aujourd'hui est
très important pour moi c'est mon seul
moyen de réparer merci
[Applaudissements]